in ancient Greece when anyone enslaved
soldiers poets and politicians you can
make a big decision on life the most
important questions like should I get
married or should we embark on this
voyage or should our army advance into
this territory they all consulted the
Oracle so this is how it worked you
would bring her question and you would
go on your knees and then she would go
into this trance they would take a
couple of days and then eventually she
would come out at it giving you her
predictions as your answer from the
oracle bones of ancient china in ancient
Greece to Mayan calendars people have
craved for prophecy in order to find out
what's going to happen next
and that's because we all want to make
the right decision we don't want to miss
something the future is scary so it's
much nicer knowing that we can make a
decision with some assurance of the
outcome well we have a new Oracle and
its name is Big Data
or we call it Watson or deep learning or
neural nets and these are the kind of
questions we ask of our Oracle now like
you know what what's the most efficient
way to ship these phones from China to
Sweden or what are the odds of my
child's being born with a genetic
disorder or what are the sales volume
who can predict for this product I have
a dog her name is Elle and she hates the
rain and I have tried everything to
untrain her but because I have failed at
this I also have to consult an Oracle
called
dark sky every time before we go on a
walk for a very accurate weather
predictions in the next 10 minutes so
sweet
so because of all of this our Oracle is
a one hundred and twenty two billion
dollar industry now despite the size of
this industry the returns are
surprisingly low investing in big data
is easy but using it is hard over 73% of
big data projects aren't even profitable
and I have executives coming up to me
saying we're experience the same thing
we invested in some big data system and
our employees aren't making better
decisions and they're certainly not
coming up with more breakthrough ideas
so this is all really interesting to me
because I'm a technology ethnographer I
study and I advise companies and the
patterns of how people use technology
and one of my interest areas of data so
why is having more data not helping us
make better decisions especially for
companies who have all these resources
to invest in these big data systems why
isn't it getting any easier for them so
I've witnessed the struggle firsthand in
2009 I started a research position with
Nokia and at the time Nokia was one of
the largest cell phone companies in the
world dominating emerging markets like
China Mexico and India all places where
I had done a lot of research on how
low-income people use technology and I
spent a lot of extra time in China
getting to know the informal economy so
I did things like working as a street
vendor selling dumplings to construction
workers or I did field work spending
nights and days in internet cafes hang
out with Chinese youths like understand
how they were using games and mobile
phones and using it between moving from
the rural areas to the cities and
through all of this qualitative evidence
that I was gathering I was starting to
see so clearly that a big change was
about to happen among low-income Chinese
people even though they were surrounded
by advertisements for luxury products
like fancy toilets
who wouldn't want one and apartments and
cars through my conversations with them
I found
how that the ads that actually enticed
them the most were the ones for iPhones
promising them this entry into this
high-tech life and even when I was
living with them and urban slums like
this one
I saw people investing over half of
their monthly income into buying a phone
and increasingly they were Shan Zhai
which are affordable knockoffs of
iPhones and other brands just they're
very usable does a job and after years
of living with migrants and working with
them and just you know really doing
everything that they were doing
I started piecing all these data points
together you know from the things that
were seem like random like me selling
dumplings so the things are more obvious
like you know tracking how much they
were spending on their cell phone bills
and I was able to create this much more
holistic picture of what was happening
and that's when I started to realize
that even the poorest in China would
want a smartphone and that they would do
almost anything to get their hands on
one and you have to keep in mind
iPhones had just come out there was 2009
so there's like eight years ago and
androids had just started looking like
iPhones and a lot of very smart and
realistic people said those smartphones
that's just as bad right who wants to
carry around these heavy things were
batteries drain quickly and they break
every time you drop them but I had a lot
of data and I was very confident about
my insights so I was very excited to
share them with Nokia but Nokia was not
convinced because it wasn't big data
they said we have millions of data
points and we don't see any indicators
of anyone wanting to buy a smart phone
and your data set of 100 OS diverse as
it is is too weak for us that you take
seriously and I said no - you're right
of course you wouldn't see this because
you know you're sending out surveys
assuming that people don't know what a
smartphone is so of course you're not
going to get any data back about people
wanting to buy a smartphone in two years
your surveys your methods have been
designed to optimize an existing
business model
and I'm looking at these emergent human
dynamics that haven't happened yet
we're you know looking outside of market
dynamics so that we can get ahead of it
well you know what happens to Nokia
their business fell off a cliff this
this is the cost of missing something it
was it was unfathomable but no he is not
alone I see organizations throwing out
data all the time because it didn't come
from a quant model or didn't fit in one
but if not big data is false it's the
way we use big data it's our
responsibility big data's reputation for
success comes from quantifying very
specific environments like electricity
power grids or delivery logistics or
genetic code when we're quantifying in
systems that are more or less contained
but not all systems are as neatly
contained when you're quantifying and
systems are more dynamic especially
systems that involve human beings forces
are complex and unpredictable and these
are things that we don't know how to
model so well once you predict something
about human behavior new factors emerge
because conditions are constantly
changing that's why if their
never-ending cycle you think you know
something and then something unknown
enters the picture and that's why just
relying on big data alone increases the
chance that we'll miss something while
giving us this illusion that we already
know everything and what makes it really
hard to see this paradox and even like
wrap our brains around it is that we
have this thing that I call the
quantification bias which is the
unconscious belief of valuing the
measurable over the immeasurable and we
often experience this at our work you
know we maybe work alongside colleagues
who are like this or even our whole
entire company maybe like this where
people become so fixated on that number
that they can't see anything outside of
it even when you present them evidence
right in front of their face and this is
a very appealing message because there
nothing wrong with quantifying it's
actually very satisfying now I get a
great sense of comfort from looking at
an Excel spreadsheet even very simple
ones just kind of like yes the formula
worked it's allocations ratings under
control but the problem is that
quantifying is addictive and when we
forget that and when we don't have
something to kind of keep that in check
it's very easy to just throw out data
because it can't be expressed as a
numerical value it's very easy to slip
into silver bullet thinking as if some
simple solution existed because this is
a great moment of danger for any
organization because oftentimes the
future we need to predict it isn't in
that haystack but it's that tornado
that's bearing down on us outside of the
barn there is no greater risk than being
blind to the unknown it can cause you to
make the wrong decisions it can cause
you to miss something big but we don't
have to go down this path it turns out
that the Oracle of ancient Greece holds
the secret key that shows us the path
forward now recent geological research
has shown that the Temple of Apollo were
the most famous Oracle stat was actually
built over two earthquakes bolts and
these bolts would release these petrol
chemical fumes from underneath the
Earth's crust and the Oracle literally
sat right above these false
inhaling enormous amounts of ethylene
gas these fissures it's all true and
that's what made her babble and
hallucinate and go into this trance-like
state she was high as a kite
so how did anyone how did anyone get any
useful advice out of her in this state
well you see those people surrounding
the Oracle you see those people holding
her up because she's like a little woozy
and you see that guy in your left hand
side folding the orange notebook
well those were the temple guides and
they worked hand in hand with the Oracle
when inquisitors would come and get on
their knees that's when the temple
guides would get to work because then
after they ask their questions they
would observe their emotional state and
then they would ask them follow-up
questions like hey why do you want to
know this prophecy who are you what are
you going to do with this information
and then the temple guides would take
this more extra graphic this more
qualitative information and interpret
the Oracles babblings so the Oracle
didn't stand alone and neither should
our big data systems now to be clear I'm
not saying that big data systems are you
know huffing ethylene gas or that
they're even giving a valid prediction
the total opposite what what I am saying
is that in the same way that the Oracles
needed her temple guides our big data
systems need them too they need people
like ethnographers and user researchers
who can gather what I call six data this
is precious data from humans like
stories emotions and interactions that
cannot be quantified if the kind of data
that I collected for Nokia that comes in
this form of a very small sample size
but delivers incredible depth of meaning
and what makes it so thick and meaty is
experience of understanding the human
narrative and that what helps us see
what's missing in our models fixated
rounds are business questions and human
questions and that's why integrating big
and thick data forms a more complete
picture big data is able to offer
insights at scale and leverage of best
of machine intelligence whereas big data
can help us rescue the context loss that
comes from making big data usable and
they leverage the best of human
intelligence
when you actually integrate the two
that's when things get really fun
because then you're no longer just
working with data you've already
collected you could to also work with
data that hasn't been collected you
could ask questions about why why is
this happening now when Netflix did this
they unlocked a whole new way to
transform their business now Netflix is
known for their really great
recommendation algorithm and they have
this one million-dollar prize for anyone
who could improve it and there were
winners but Netflix discovered that the
improvements were only incremental so to
really find out what was going on they
hired an ethnographer grant McCracken to
gather stick data insights and what he
discovered was something that they
hadn't seen initially in the
quantitative data he discovered that
people love to binge watching in fact
people didn't even feel guilty about it
they enjoyed it so Netflix was like oh
this is a new insight so they went to
their data science team and they were
able to scale the stick data insight
into with their quantitative data and
once they verified it and validate it
Netflix decided to do something very
simple but impactful they said instead
of offering the same show from different
genres or more to the different shows
from similar users we'll just offer more
of a same show
we'll make it easier for you to binge
watch and they didn't stop there they
redid all these things to redesign their
entire viewer experience to really
encourage veg watching why people and
friends disappear for whole weekends at
a time catching up on shows like masters
of nutin by integrating big data and big
data they not only improve their
business but they transform how we
consume media and now their stocks are
projected to double in the next few
years but this isn't just about you know
watching more videos or selling more
smart phones for some integrating thick
data insights into the algorithm could
mean life or death especially for the
marginalized
all around the country police
departments are using big data for
predictive policing to set bond amounts
and sentencing recommendations in ways
that reinforce existing biases NSA
Skynet machine learning the algorithm
has possibly aided in a deaths of
thousands of civilians in Pakistan from
mistreating cellular device metadata as
all of our lives become more automated
from automobiles to health insurance or
to employment it is likely that all of
us will be impacted by the
quantification bias now the good news is
that we've come a long way from huffing
ethylene gas to make predictions we have
better tools so let's just use them
better let's integrate the big data with
the big data let's bring our temple
guides with the Oracles and whether this
work happens in companies or nonprofits
or government nor even in the software
all of it matters because that means
we're collectively committed to making
better data better algorithms better
outputs and better decisions this is how
we'll avoid missing that something
[Applause]
[Music]